the afternoon is worn itself on fire now
it will be done well if it's time to let
the cotton and tobacco go time to get
the mules and first time to milk the
cows
did you see cows time to quit work and
head for home
time for supper our men get it - corn
pone rich turnip and four stops
maybe it's been a long day and
thermistor in
now our sufferings over in this evening
time and this is the time we want to
talk about our story is about the time
of day when it is getting dark and cool
about resting time this is resting time
a time to sit quietly and talk and play
some music and sing a little
if you've got a voice for singing but
this resting time is a danger time to
the hours would come after dusk our
swings are at our most eager hours from
dark stood on the malaria carrying
mosquitoes search for food and they
fight people who are sleeping or sitting
quietly the cool hours of the early dark
or dangerous this is a time when the
mosquitoes do their worst at this hour
the call of come and get it echoes over
the swamps and mosquitos come to find
the sufferer come and get it echoes in
the dark days con men get it animus
Peter come from the sinkholes
from pools toklas grass weeds twigs and
flowers from creeks
crowded with water plants from all these
places maecenas comes searching for
sufferers and they come from their
hiding places in holosuite jump from the
dark cool corners behind beds from the
dark cool corners of staples from the
dark cool corners of barn yes evening is
tougher time for the malaria mosquitoes
too they leave the West places where
they breathe in the dark cool places
where they hide during the heat of the
day and they come looking for their
supper they come looking for you or
somebody like you looking for people
this is another squad semester up you
can call her quad for short you can
recognize her by the way she stands on
her head - Quentin price did other
mosquitoes and fun stuff it's annoying
but it said give you molest but remember
this one the mosquito that stands on his
head the malaria mosquito he doesn't
make much noise and her face doesn't
sting okay so the little girls would
won't tell anything about the bus not
now but in a few weeks we call it Swamp
fever chills I hope you but whatever
it's called
this is mer area he shivered with cold
for a few hours and then burned with
fever
have malaria still tired and weak for
many months
this is malaria malaria The Tempest and
the body of the mosquito to the body of
the Christians when the mosquito bite
malaria makes million fish every year
men from work in the field and women
from working the home malaria where's
people bound and it wears them up and
when a man's run down his ran runs down
and his home runs out and his wife and
his children they run down to America
doesn't kill many but it makes millions
unfit for work that makes them poor and
it keeps near Carl malaria just two
people the little girl is sick with
malaria
he's had no treatment now a mosquito
bites her again then take some blood
from her body and with her blood takes
malaria the sickness grows in a
mosquitoes body in a few weeks if that
mosquito comes back to this house and
infects one of the family by biting them
best person will become system a few
weeks later he got killed and fever
mosquito I think in the malaria from his
sister's blood and put it into his brush
the farmer looks at both his children
and worries and says to stick in the
house narrow
yeah no we were thinking about the money
at his clothes we can't let him go on
like this and I have got to have him in
the fields I can't make don't mean
that's a garden so the doctor comes he
examines the boy and his sister what
looks like malaria but the doctor makes
sure he takes a few drops of blood from
the finger of each patient the blood is
smeared on a small piece of grass then
the brothers examined under the powerful
magnifying glass of a microscope in the
laboratory
this is what the microscope show those
little dots in the blood distrusted
officials those are the parasites that
cause malaria now the doctor is sure and
we give Jim and his sister why not
sometimes the doctor prescribed ever
brain or another medicine with medicine
destroys the malaria in their blood and
helps them get well some people need
special treatment the doctor decides
what best treatment should be and then
the doctor speaks for the promise but if
you want to protect your family against
malaria other things you have to do by
putting mosquito netting over both the
fish bed that's five meters away
something and then the commuters won't
be able to fight something care than the
merit of somebody up on the pieces
well start getting better food Larry
doesn't bother people long if they get
the right kind of treatment should be up
and around in a few days anyway I told
you the most comfortable he began but
there the last month in Judas event male
manual didn't help eager to get health
officer little too much the fish can to
get and a week or so later the health
officer comes to the house and tells the
farmer what he can do to protect his
family against malaria that the stream
is full with fine wire from the marianas
Eidos
can't go through all the windows should
be screen well to keep my Marilyn hours
and keep mosquitoes out well every
ultimately goes on after measurements we
don't move must be covered or three to
put out a lot of money 15 this time of
year it doesn't cost a lot of money
Matt you have to put out at one time but
it only comes with our three thousand
here most of you folks are spending
about twenty-five dollars every year for
medicine there's a lot
the bathroom I guess it is money's right
here this time of year if you're sort of
ready cash you're not far away you gotta
protect your family when the Ripper
scream and I'll figure how to put it up
but even with the prenup you better job
you better look for mosquitos love a dog
to clownish weather hi look behind the
base and in the dark cool paper than the
bomb wherever the dark cool place before
a vet when the Cheetos high and when
your friend mosquitos they've got a
possum turn them with a spray gun those
are the things you can do to fight
malaria to keep yourself and your family
healthy and it works
Latinos oh but there's more to the death
the mosquitos must be destroyed that is
your community's job malaria mosquitoes
lay their eggs in warm pools and ponds
near the banks of quietly mineral water
plain pond can be dreamy so that the
mosquitos will have no Prince to lay
there is sometimes fun can be filled to
destroy the breeding places of the
malaria mosquito larvae or wiggle tails
that hatch out of the malaria it must be
the way breasts that the water did make
the protesters print for the larvae when
the breast is cut away this protection
may destroy the living water and so they
become full-grown mosquitoes poisoned us
spread on the water kills there we go
they
coil-spring on the surface of the water
fills the windows hello to in some
places friends are used to spray water
was poisoned up all these things have to
be done by people who know how people
tend to do the work it's a big job it
takes a long time and costs a lot of
money but it doesn't cost much as
malaria costs and it prevents the
sickness and suffering with malaria
brings the community must get rid of
malaria mosquitoes for good was just an
oil with permanent draining system
between
no quiet water and grapeseed machiners
can lay there is but until the community
does this you have a job to do in your
home your trip your moving home we've
got to keep mosquitos out clean the
doors and windows cover the fireplaces
to keep them from coming down through
the chimney cover the cracks in the
floor cover the cracks in the walls and
ceiling those things are your job if you
need help your property can tell you how
to keep mosquitoes and malaria out of
your house how to protect your home and
family
that's malaria so that you can be strong
to do the work that must be done strong
to live well go that way a million time
common threats in time you can rest in
sleep remember the mosquito that stands
on her head can put you flat on your
back ask yourself a subpoena for advice
mosquitos out malaria